[Musique]
devant cette fonderie d'acier à une
trentaine de kilomètres au nord de Kiev
des familles de civils ukrainien
emprisonnés depuis presque un an en
Russie
ils ont emmené mon fils et mon mari le
même jour ils sont venus chez nous et
ils les ont emmenés on m'a dit qu'ils
étaient en prison en Russie mais je ne
sais rien d'autre
avant de déporter 42 civils depuis ce
village les rues s'en ont détenu une
centaine dans cette usine pour des
raisons totalement arbitraires
députés la ravassili VA smarlouk tente
de leur venir en aide
quelqu'un avait par exemple un tatouage
avec un trident ukrainien ou une carte
de l'Ukraine incluant la Crimée
un autre avait des ampoules au doigt et
ils ont estimé que cette personne savait
tirer le problème principal de ces
prisonniers civils c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas soumis à la Convention de Genève ils
peuvent pas être échangés
le 3 mars va-t-il Youk et son fils
dimitro son plaqués au sol et
déshabiller par 5 soldats
des métros et journalistes à l'agence de
presse ukrainiennes unian
son père et lui seront détenus ici
pendant 10 jours dans des conditions
inhumaines
ici c'était notre prison avec mon fils
nous étions allongé là à même le sol
[Musique]
et là il y avait le seau excrément
tous les soirs il ramenait de nouveau
prisonniers il y avait des gens partout
[Musique]
nous étions nombreux et très à l'étroit
nous avions les mains attachées les yeux
bandés avec du scotch on pouvait
entrevoir par le bas mais de toute façon
il n'y avait pas de lumière ni le jour
ni la nuit
interdit de parole
on nous a dit si vous parlez je vous
jette une grenade les prisonniers sont
gardés dans le froid sans couverture ni
matelas
on a trouvé un baril avec de l'eau de
l'usine pour les batteries et on buvait
cette eau
ils nous ont dit qu'ils ne nous en
donnerait pas car il n'y avait plus
d'eau au village
et pour la nourriture il nous donnait
parfois une ration de soldats
dans le noir certains parvenaient en
avoir d'autres non au bout de son
calvaire voici les relâcher
son fils lui au dernier nouvelle
transmise par des témoins serait dans
une prison du sud de la Russie
cette lettre m'a été transmise par la
Croix-Rouge il n'y a que trois mots
maman je suis vivant
au Lena dirige une petite clinique à
rostomel au nord de Bucha
quand la Russie attaque l'Ukraine le 24
février les temps première ligne
le 25 février il y avait déjà 40 blessés
civils à hostomel nous leur prodiguions
les premiers secours dans cette clinique
puis les occupants sont venus et ils
nous ont chassés ils ont fait cette
clinique leur base
mais le pire pour Léna et sa famille
arrive après presque un mois de guerre
et d'occupation
hier
dans la cour sur un grill car nous
n'avions ni l'électricité ni le gaz un
soldat russe est venu et il a tiré sur
mon mari
il l'a blessé à la hanche au genou ils
l'ont mis à terre avec un coup de cross
dans la tête ils ont mis un pistolet
dans sa bouche et un autre sur sa tempe
mon fils a entendu le bruit il est sorti
dehors s'est mis à genoux et à supplier
ne tuez pas mon père je me suis mise
devant mon fils pour le protéger
laissant le grand-père de 82 ans à la
maison les soldats embarquent le père
blessé la mer et le fils à bord d'un
blindé
la raison probable le père est un
retrait de la police ukrainienne
ils nous ont assis dans un couloir ils
ont mis des sacs en plastique sur nos
têtes nous avions les mains liées ils
ont attaché ces sacs avec du scotch
autour de notre cou mon fils m'a dit
maman je ne peux plus respirer je
n'avais jamais rien entendu d'aussi
terrible de toute ma vie
après 20 secondes ils ont fait des trous
dans ces sacs pour qu'on puisse respirer
puis ils nous ont emmenés dans un blindé
à l'aéroport d'Antonov là-bas j'ai senti
la présence de mon fils pour la dernière
fois
libéré après avoir perdu connaissance
Solena rentre chez elle et a-t-on le
retour de son mari et de son fils
un mois et demi c'est cool puis l'armée
ukrainienne libère rostomènes
les 10 premiers jours après la
Libération je devais examiner tous les
cadavres qu'il y avait à au sommet
chaque fois j'y allais dans l'espoir de
ne pas trouver mon fils et mon mari
parmi eux j'ai vu des gens qui avaient
les mains liées derrière le dos et
avaient pris une balle dans la nuque
j'ai vu tant de choses à pensables que
je n'oublierai et ne pardonnerai jamais
le 19 avril le mari d'olena rentre à la
maison
il aura passé un mois d'abord dans un
camp de filtration en Biélorussie puis
une prison en Russie
il a perdu 20 kilos en un mois à son
arrivée à la maison d'arrêt de Koursk
ils lui ont cassé deux côtes au même
endroit ils ont battu à mort l'un de nos
habitants de hostomel il lâche les
chiens sur nos gens pourquoi moi en
médecin civile on m'a mis un sac sur la
tête pourquoi mon mari un retraitée
a-t-il reçu un coup de cross sur la tête
et une balle dans le genou pourquoi mon
fils est-il otage depuis presque un an
passé
comme Olena les familles d'au moins 5000
prisonniers civils Ukrainiens attendent
des nouvelles et espère chaque jour le
retour de leurs proches